but first joe's european giveaway
that's the focus of tonight's angle
now after uh kamala's disastrous trip to
central america you can see why the
media
they're desperate to switch topics so
her avoidance of the border reflects so
badly on the administration
that the only way they can turn the page
was to feature biden
appearing strong right and command and
eager to re-engage with europe
there was one little problem though joe
biden
in libya we should be opening up the the
the passes to be able to go through
provide
provide um food assistance and economic
ass i mean
vital assistance to uh a population
that's in real trouble
for example the rebuilding of uh of
syria of uh of libya
wait wait by the way how does mr foreign
policy mix up syria with libya
oh it's this is i gotta say guys this is
unfair it's confusing because
both countries do end with the
ia sound at the end so it's very
confusing
well the entire g7 and its aftermath
reminded me of how hard it is to take
like elderly relatives and many of you
have done this before you want to take
them out of their retirement home for
the day
and show them some you know fun times
and some activities
and then they end up just spending much
of the time
pretending to understand what's going on
around them
right and then the rest of the time they
just seem bewildered
to the point where their minders
sometimes us have to politely try to
cover for them
vladimir putin laughed at the suggestion
that you had called him
a killer is that still your belief sir
that he is a killer
i'm laughing too they actually i
well look i mean he has made clear that
uh
the answer is i believe he is in the
past
essentially acknowledged that he was uh
there are certain things that he would
do or did do
the short answer is yes president biden
very clearly still believes president
putin
is a killer but you could see the
strategic calculation as he was deciding
where he was going to go with that
answer and then how he ended it making
clear
that this is the reality
that was the minder translating joe for
you
now the entire event seemed like an
ongoing exercise in elder abuse
complete with scam artists like this
time the europeans who spend their time
patronizing the patient all the while
working to drain his bank account
except in this case of elder abuse it's
america's bank account
and our independence that's at risk
it's great to have a u.s president
part of the club and are you willing to
to cooperate
with joe biden you sort of feel that um
he he wants to he's he's a great
believer in the transatlantic alliance
of course they're happy and then the
press
was gushing in one way
anna he had them at hello right he was
just
there saying i want to be a part of the
g7 i want to be a part of the world
community yeah i think they're relieved
that the united states is in some ways
the united states they remember
that you've got a more traditional
american uh presence life
predictable traditional maybe a little
boring but
i think we know which way the world
prefers it
of course that's the way the world
prefers it
nations like france and germany prefer
biden because with him
they have outsized leverage they'll get
most of what they want
and then they'll give up nothing
meanwhile america gets stiffed and our
taxpayers well of course we pick up the
bill
now both the media and the democrats
they want to keep this entire
conversation as you can hear it in the
press coverage
just steeped in generalities they don't
want you to know what's
actually in this 25-page g7
communique that biden ended up agreeing
to
now why don't they want you to know
what's in it if it's such a great
accomplishment
because it's a sovereignty killing
prosperity destroying series of policy
pronouncements
that would never get past our own
congress
here are some of the low lights vaccine
passports oh yay if you're worried about
being forced to show your papers
for travel well you should be things
sound
ominous on the vaccine passport issue
with the g7 recognizing the need for
a set of common standards for travel
including interoperability and mutual
recognition of
digital applications testing
requirements and recognition of
vaccination status well well how would
any of this be possible
without an actual digital vaccination
certificate next item
well goodbye cars here's the relevant
language here
we commit to accelerate the transition
away from new sales of diesel and petrol
cars
to promote the uptake of zero emission
vehicles
well we kind of like elon musk i've said
that before
and i'm glad he's happy but this isn't
anything that joe biden has
the authority or voter mandate to commit
to
the big anti-fossil fuels umbrella
provision
is ripped right from that international
energy agency report
that we warned you about some weeks ago
biden reaffirmed his commitment to the
goal of net zero carbon emissions across
all sectors of our economies and
societies
my friends this will destroy hundreds of
thousands
of the good paying american jobs that
are left here drive up energy costs for
every living american devastate our
national security as we'll lose our
energy independence of course the cost
of everything's going up
fuel costs going up now as part of this
biden
wants not only your car your gas powered
car
but also it kind of like your fridge and
your favorite lamp as well
the document references this nifty
acronym called
seed s-e-a-d which refers to super
efficient equipment and
appliance deployment initiative
requiring new
systems by 2030.
so get ready to shell out big bucks if
you like
low flow toilets you'll love paying more
while you're getting less
from all your appliances but a few
groups
i've got to say will do just fine in
this g7 document like wall street
and global bureaucrats now this comes
from the
goal to jointly mobilize a hundred
billion dollars per year
from public and private sources for
meaningful mitigation actions
what's that and increasing public
climate finance contributions
i'm going to translate this for you
you're going to pay more
for a lower standard of living while
bureaucrats make more
money and along with this greeniac
boondoggle or sweetheart d
heart deals for wall street they're
going to be cashing in
as governments quote develop the global
green finance market
in order to quote mobilize the trillions
of dollars of private sector finance
needed
to meet net zero emissions
so it's kind of like during the pandemic
even when american families got poorer
big corporate interests got a lot richer
of course though no biden buy-in would
be complete
without a nod to the gender fluidity
crowd
the document pretends to safeguard women
and girls empowerment
while at the same time supporting
diversity including of sexual
orientations
and gender identities okay this is the
angle shorthand for you kids
boys and men should be able to play and
even dominate
girls and women's athletics three manly
cheers for girl power
so what did biden get for all this
nonsense that will weaken the us
vis-a-vr g7 counterparts remember
during the campaign he bragged that
under a biden administration
he with all his foreign policy
experience was going to be able to use
his influence with our allies to get
tough on china
instead he comes home with a limp
pointless statement saying we will
continue to consult on collective
approaches to challenging non-market
policies and practices
we will cooperate where it is in our
mutual interest on shared global
challenges
in particular addressing climate change
and biodiversity laws yeah i'm sure
china is going to be up
late at night about that they go out of
their way by the way
not to offend china by including only a
very tip and very general bland mention
of respecting human rights without ever
mentioning the uyghurs by name
and of course they'll never use the word
genocide
this is a complete abdication to china
they are
celebrating tonight it's a total failure
on the part of joe biden
in response to this all of this
republicans on the hill
have to get their messaging right and
deliver it with precision and clarity
it should go something like this for our
alliance to survive with the g7
countries
it must be between american america and
our foreign partners
not our foreign partners in the democrat
party
but right now joe biden is promising
he's promising to write checks
that he won't be able to cash they're
not going to be able to ever get the
money from
biden does not have the power to agree
to any of this and he certainly doesn't
have the support of the american people
to do it
so we're going to put everyone on notice
we're going to retake the house next
year
then we're going to retake the white
house in 2024
and when we do we're going to shred this
document as soon as we can
thus when we get a president who's
actually looking out for america's
interest again
don't say we didn't warn you this entire
g7
exercise is a waste of time it's
completely invalid
biden himself though seems to know he's
in a bit of a jam given the political
realities at home
the republican party is vastly
diminished in numbers
the leadership of the republican party
is
fractured and the
trump wing of the party is the bulk of
the party
but it makes up a significant minority
of the american people
i know who wrote that for him but that
was nice try joe but liz cheney and adam
kinzinger
make up about i don't know what two
percent of the gop gop the rest of it's
america first baby
even cnn sees where this is headed
although it pathetically tries to tie
the futility of the g7 meeting
to january 6 somehow the european
leaders
they trust president by another relief
at the g7
and nato summits clearly palpable after
four years of trump but do they trust
the united states right now do they
trust congress in the aftermath
let's say of january 6 and the
insurrection on the u.s capitol
less so less so and i mean one of the
reasons you saw
no movement on climate finance despite
the fact that biden brought the united
states back into the paris climate
accord
and has appointed john kerry to a
cabinet position on climate is precisely
because they don't believe
that the u.s legislature is going to get
a lot done
yeah well hello of course they're not
here's an idea
let's have joe biden try to pass any of
what he agreed to
over in europe through congress you know
that whole democratic process thing they
claim to care so much about
the same one they claim was threatened
on january 6th
remember when donald trump happy
birthday mr president traveled to these
international confabs the global elites
were very gloomy
they knew he wasn't a sucker for their
charades america came first for him
and where we had shared gold with our
european partners he tried to forge
common ground that made sense
mccrone and merkel knew though that
biden was
always going to be as an easy touch pun
intended
a few references to build back better in
that communique
was all it took to get his team of fools
to agree to a document filled with
great reset giveaways to special
interests
republicans have to make it crystal
clear joe may be a cheap date
but america is not whatever his
endearing
bumbling qualities uncle chucklehead
does not have the mandate for any of
this
the voters who turned out for biden did
so thinking he'd protect
our interests not work against them
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else